welcome everyone back to the final topic
of today's workshop so we have my
laundry telling us about revisiting post
quantification yeah thanks for inviting
me and just a word of warning I'm
sharing a 900 foot home with a baby who
might be making weight at some point so
yeah bear with me okay
so I mean we've been talking in the
previous two talks but they're in
workable model and the quantum setting
and this more generally there's an issue
that we have all these great lattice
crypto papers but lattice crypto isn't
necessarily the same as quantum crypto
so even though we have that the
underlying lattice problems are presumed
hard in most works in the lattice crypt
the literature the security proof is a
classical reduction which shows how to
convert a classical attacker into an
algorithm for those problems and if you
combine the two of these together it
does not yield the desired security goal
in the post quantum setting necessarily
what you need for this is actually a
proof quantum crypto theorem which says
that you can convert any quantum
attacker into a quantum algorithm for
lattice problems and then you combine
this with the assumption that these
lattice prongs are coming apart and then
indeed you would get the desired
security goal so in the sense of post
quantum crypto most of the lattice crypt
of literature is on the left here loose
you know
rickety leaky tower give it giving just
a classical reduction and where we
really want to be is on this nice grand
castle on the right over here where we
actually have a quantum reduction now it
turns out that the good news is a vast
majority approves
it's basically trivial to update the
classical reduction to a quantum
reduction you can just go through and
replace every instance of probabilistic
polynomial-time of quantum polynomial
time and everything will sort of
magically work but there are some key
exceptions one that we've already been
seeing today is
is this quantum random Oracle model and
another one that I will also be talking
about is something called rewinding okay
so this this clock is going to be
religiously the general picture I'll
sort of wear this this paper wise and
for this talk in particular I'm going to
be talking about signatures so how do we
build signatures from lattices well
there's a couple main ways you might try
to do this so one is to build you think
glass that gives you a one-way function
we know that one of functions actually
imply signatures using some nice
theoretical work from a few decades ago
and the good news is that this nice
theoretical work is this sort of strain
easy path and you can update I can
basically replace PPT with you PT and
you get a quantum proof another category
of signatures is those based on the hash
and fine paradigm here it's a it's a
little more complicated so there's some
work so they've shown how to instantiate
the fashion sign paradigm in standard
model and here again it's relatively
straightforward to just sort of update
the proofs to work upon the Packers on
the other hand there there are other
signatures of the hash and find variety
that only have security proofs in the
random Oracle model and so here we have
this one barrier proving security it's
certainly non-trivial but this is this
particular case is sort of the first
type of scheme that we ever knew how to
prove in the quantum random Oracle model
and we have a pretty good idea in
general Tautou to handle this so while
there is this barrier it's been pretty
much fall the last type of Oh question
yeah you know so so when you say
signatures with a quantum attacker do
you mean that sorry do you mean that the
attacker can make quantum signature
queries I can give you a superposition
of messages and for this talk I'm only a
mat I'm only considering classical
signing queries which is that the
complete
the attacker has a quantum computer
handling quantum signature queries is
actually that one is non-trivial that
there is no sort of straight path but
for probably most real-world
applications we don't care so much about
attackers that can make quantum
signature queries for the most part were
probably okay restricting the attacker
to making classical queries but were
concerned with an attacker who you know
Michael if upon a computer to do
computation from the side right so in
the standard model things should be okay
and in the random Oracle model you have
to deal with the quantum random Oracle
Hat star right right and as we'll see
the random Oracle model isn't the only
barrier there is also a barrier of
rewinding which we'll talk about in this
clock so without will bring me to the
last main category of lattices
signatures which is to build your
signature scheme you can the C Edgemere
transformation and here we actually see
both barriers both the Fiat the Fiat
ramier transformation is the random
Oracle model transformation and then as
we'll see proving the original security
of the protocol you the interactive
protocol you begin with before you even
apply fiat shmear that protocol is going
to involve a rewinding step in security
proof and this is going to be a problem
for quantum attackers for a quantum
reduction so there have been a number of
works showing partial solutions to the
Fiat smear problem in the quantum
setting either showing how to get around
winding or to get around with random
Oracle model business but if our goal is
to sort of work with the unmodified pH
mirror applied to the chef's keys a
signature scheme or the many of the
schemes based on it without modifying
them there are these barriers and I
should note that the modifications used
to remove these barriers usually result
in a reduction in efficiency so there is
a sort of a practical importance here
so in this work we show how to get
around both barriers so first we show
that th mirror is full quantum secured
in the random Oracle model and then we
also give new techniques for quantum
rewinding and by combining our theorem
with these new techniques we can show
that for example I wish F skis signature
scheme from lattices is actually post
quantum secure assuming it learning with
errors but making no modification for
the protocol so this is the summary of
this work and I should mention that
though the left half of the work was
actually there was a concurrent work
that appeared simultaneously with this
paper that did the left half and I'll
actually compare our works a little bit
more later on but the right half floats
or unique so not yeah
so you're something that really are you
saying there are only two things here
one is to prove that the an interactive
protocol is like you know diversity for
example is there is a is sound you know
potentially uses rewinding and then you
need to deal with it and two is actually
assuming it is quantumly sound compile
it with the random Oracle model that's
enough exactly is that okay okay so with
that let me go into the quantum back I
know you have seen two quantum random
Oracle model parts already but I want to
put a little investment in and talking
about quantum in a particular way and it
will pay off later because it'll make
describing or results a lot less
complicated so to motivate the the
background let's imagine a sort of
simple model of a stochastic process a
classical lacasa process where we we
have some system that starts out in the
certain state and I'm going to imagine
the states being represented by these
slots in the in the
here so I have I have a classical system
it starts on from sleep and then I
operated on some way potentially
probabilistically and I'll take another
snapshot at a later point in time and
what I'll see is that there's some
transition probabilities that say what's
the probability that the starting state
goes to you know the first slots here at
this later point in time your second
third fourth and then I can operate a
lot more with some another probabilistic
process look at the state again operator
more look at the state again and so
forth so in doing so what happens is my
state sort of goes through a path
through all these through this picture
here and these paths are the this notion
of a path is going to keep coming out
throughout the talk so so the in the
classical setting we'll just think of
the you could imagine for example
concretely like I actually have a
particle and it's traveling through the
system actually going through these
slots or you could think of it more
abstractly is just a general process but
I thinking about a particle is kind of
nice because you actually then know what
the particle does is exactly the path is
home so I'm going to define this notion
of a wake for a path which is just the
the product of all these transition
probabilities on the path from start to
finish and because these this is
actually just the probability that my my
system will will follow this path now
let's suppose I decide to look at my
system at some some later point in time
and I want to know what the state of the
system is at that time and I'll see that
it's in some state why what's the
probability that I showed up and why
well you can easily convince yourself
that the probability that I land in Y is
just the sum over all possible paths
from s to Y of the weight of those
pounds
okay I haven't done anything anything
interesting yet what gets interesting is
how we interpret quantum in this view so
when I search the quantum a couple
interesting things are going to happen
so first my my transition values are no
longer going to be probabilities they're
going to be complex amplitudes so they
can be - there can be negatives there
can be things that aren't even real so
I'm going to replace my my real valued
probabilities with these complex
amplitudes
but I'm still going to define the weight
of a path the same way it's just going
to be the product of the amplitudes or
weights over these paths so this means
though that the weight of the path isn't
necessarily among the it is a number
they can in general be a complex number
so how do I go from these these weights
to actual probabilities well if I'm
going to view my system at a later point
in time and actually learn what the
state of the system is what I will see
is that the probability of landing in a
particular state Y is no longer the sum
of the weights of all paths from s to Y
but it's actually the sum and then I
take the absolute value in the square
root so this is mathematically the the
change going from classical computing to
quantum computing is I replace
non-negative real probabilities with
complex amplitudes and the way I go
between those and probabilities is to do
a square
so this view I actually really like it
because it makes a lot of this phenomena
that you may have heard of in quantum
computing it actually makes it very easy
to explain
Macha suggestion why are you taking the
square of the sum is of the sum of the
squares good so if I did if I did the
sum of the squares I actually would just
get back classical stochastic process
and the reason that we do at the this
other way this is derived from physics
if I won't really go into that but this
is you know once you you know derive
from physics the mathematical
abstraction of quantum computing this is
what you would get maybe one way to
think about it is you know if you're
familiar with this like the double slit
experiments which is one of the early
experiments predating quantum mechanics
so the point is that these paths were
actually the paths that actual particles
went on and the way and the the
observation of the value Y was really
something like looking at the energy or
the the energy of a detect or something
like that and the way you go from
something like an electric field to to
energy is you do involve a square so
there is there's sort of some physical
intuition for why why the square comes
out but for this plot to think of it as
sort of the mathematical model of what
quantum quantum computing is it's a mark
yes you know like what was just if you
take the absolute value of the weight of
a single path then it's a product of
absolute values of each of these like
transition numbers which is then becomes
probabilities that's right right so if I
did it in the other way there's really
nothing different about quantum and
classical except that I for some reason
I'll represented my probabilities by
complex numbers whose square is that
probability but by doing things in this
way where I take the square at the end
we actually get a number of interesting
consequence
in particular this captures of hope
interference that the other right right
so so here kind of a domain and to the
difference between quantum and classical
is that because of the squaring first
you can actually have these pads
interfere constructively and actually
you sort of get more than the sum of
either path because you end up taking
the square after you song and you can
actually all because the weights on
these paths can be negative you can
actually have destructive interference
and have a bunch of different paths with
high weights lead to a particular value
but then all the paths interfere
destructively and you actually never
will see that value yes sorry this is
Rachel here I just want to ask a quick
question that can I do these different
ISS applying different sort of these
quantum operations on these particles
yes I'm thinking of it roughly as you
sort of apply some some operation this
could be an elementary gates or it could
be something more complex you apply an
operation sort of talk about what the
state of the system is apply another
operation talked about okay
okay so so what are some consequences so
here here's here's some one consequence
let's go back to the stochastic setting
and let's suppose I don't just observe
on the value Y at the very end but also
at some intermediate point I observe the
value at
what's the probability of observing both
X&Y well it's relatively easy to see
that what you do now is you to sum the
paths from s to Y that also goes through
X and now let's suppose I observe X and
I and I observe Y but now I forget
X
so I do is a marginalized out the
variable acts by summing over the
probabilities by summing over all X of
the probability of x and y and routine
calculation shows that you indeed get
the probability of Y back that you
started from
okay this is totally unsurprising but
what happens when you move the quantum
is something actually very interesting
happens if I observe acts and I observe
why the probability of x and y is what
you would expect it's the probability
decides the sum of the weights of all
paths from s to X to Y that sum squared
but here if I observe X I observed Y and
then I forget what X was so if I try to
marginalize out X I take the thumb over
X of the probabilities of x and y if I
write out the expression I will see that
it certainly does not match the
probability of observing why
so what on earth happened did I just
disprove quantum mechanics
no what happened is that observing acts
meant that the so I have all these paths
potentially going to Y and they leave
these paths going to Y travel through
different X but when I observe X now
I've forced those paths no longer
interfere
because I've sort of resolved which acts
the past is actually going through so
the past for different acts can no
longer interfere and what this leads to
is the observer effect or as goes by
many names I'll call it the observer
effect which is that if I learn anything
about a quantum system
I actually am necessarily disturbing it
so by by learning what X was even if I
later completely forgot what X was I'm
actually changing the probability
distribution over my later observation Y
you
so here's another potentially
interesting consequence so you may have
heard that quantum mechanics is
reversible why is it often said that
quantum mechanics is reversible well in
order to make the math work out that
these that the square of these
probabilities these the square of the
sum of the path weights actually gives
us the probability distribution it turns
out that the transition matrices so the
matrices that I take by I take I get by
taking all the transition weights and
assembling them into a matrix so now
that these transition matrices have to
preserve to norm which implies that
they're a unitary and unitary matrices
are invertible so this means that the
sort of basic operations of quantum
mechanics going between these layers are
invertible operation but we also have
this extra thing called a measurement or
an observation and when I observe when I
actually observe the state and learn
which which state the the paths are
going through as we just saw on the
previous slide I'm actually irreversibly
altering the state so in some sense
quantum mechanics is actually inherently
irreversible once I once I throw in
measurement and therefore this will be
very important later on the other hand
you could ask the same thing about
classical mechanics so in the classical
sarcastic view we have we also get a
condition on what the transit transition
matrices look like and it turns out that
they have to preserve one norm and these
types of matrices are called stochastic
matrices but the kassig matrices in
general could be singular there's no
guarantee that they're invertible so
this might suggest that classical
mechanics is irreversible whereas
quantum mechanics is reversible but
remember that with classical mechanics
you can always observe the current state
at any point in time and this does not
affect the trajectory of the system and
what this means is in some sense we can
always turn a classical process that
might have been irreversible it's one
that is
that one that is reversible bye-bye
recording or state at any given point in
time and then if we ever want to return
to it we can just we can just go back to
it so in some sense the classical
stochastic process is reversible one and
and it's a little touch on this
difference later so yes I actually like
to think of quantum mechanics is being
irreversible and classical being
reversible which is the opposite of what
you may have may normally hear okay so
so that's that's the background on
quantum that I wanted to talk about so
now I want to get into the first part of
the talk which is fetch mirror and the
quantum random Oracle model okay so
here's the future transformation
we'll think of it as a transformation
from three-round public coin on a
verifier proof of knowledge into non
interactive proof of knowledge and how
do you do this you do this by simply
setting the verifiers message because of
public coin you'll set the verifiers
message to just be the hash of the first
provers message so call the first
troopers message the commitment the
cycles of improvement is from the
verifier the challenge and then the last
is the response so I set the challenge
to be hash of the response using some
hash function and so this will think of
it as being a way to compress the rounds
of proofs of knowledge it's also a way
to turn identification protocol the
proofs of knowledge and signatures so
the problem with fiat ramírez we don't
know how to in general base the security
on collision resistance or any simple
property of the hash function so we have
to treat the hash function as a random
Oracle and how does your work in the
random Oracle model so let's suppose we
have an adversary that can try to post
on this we haven't we assume we have an
adversary that generates
a valid proof by after making some
queries to the random Oracle what we're
going to do is we're going to turn this
adversary into one that actually breaks
the interactive protocol so classically
how does this work what we're going to
do is we're going to select a random
query a random one of the random Oracle
queries that's the auditory makes with
call I star so when the adversary makes
his queries to the random Oracle the the
on the eye on all queries about the I
stars query we're just going to simulate
the random Oracle by choosing a random
value and replying with that the
interesting thing happens on the
specially chosen query I star here we
will take the adversaries input that
they submitted to the random Oracle
query and we will interpret that as the
first message in the proof and we will
send this to the verifier so we'll send
the I stars query to the verifier the
verify will respond with a challenge and
we will just program the output of the
random Oracle on the I start query to
develop whatever the challenge was and
then we keep going eventually the
adversary outputs there yet schmeared
proof we just check that we basically
guessed the right I star we check that
they their commitment was the one that
we we got from there I start the query
and we check that they use the same
challenge and you can you can analyze
this and show that you succeed that the
app that you know if the adversary
succeeds then the the response must
actually be a valid response to to the
your interaction with the verifier and
the bit doesn't happen with two small
abilities so this is the classical
reduction I did
but of course now we're talking about
quantum attackers and in the real world
this random Oracle is a hash function
that the quantum attacker can interact
with using quantum interactions and so
the only thing that makes sense to do is
to allow our random Oracle model
attacker to also will query the random
Oracle using quantum interaction so we
need to come up with a proof that works
in this quantum random Oracle model but
there are a number of problems with
doing so and to illustrate those
problems I want to give I want to sort
of describe what a query algorithm looks
like in the past view of quantum
computing so in this path view what I
will imagine these various snapshots in
time are are the various queries the
attacker is making to the random Oracle
and then the final snapshot of the
algorithm is there's going to be
whatever the output so the way wherever
I said that quantum operation has to be
unitary so the way that if I need to
actually model a query as a unitary
operation and the way this is generally
modeled is that the query for the query
input is actually a domain element to
the hash function and some value Y in
the range of the hash function and the
query operation X or H of the domain
element into the Y value all right
so so what's the problem with pH Mirror
in the quantum random Oracle model so
the first problem is that if you think
about the classical proof at some point
I actually had to observe the attackers
query in order to get the commitment
that the reduction is sent to the
verifier but remember that we have this
observation effect which says that
observing this commitment actually is
going to disturb the
Kirsti and maybe at this point the
attacker just decides to stop working
maybe we disturbed him in a way that he
will no longer operate then we will not
actually be able to complete the
protocol because we'll never get a good
response out of them another issue is
the usual on-the-fly simulation of the
random Oracle and the reason is that the
attacker can basically send path through
all possible inputs to the hash function
and then later on try to manipulate them
and get them to interfere with each
other in some way so in some sense the
entire trajectory of the attacker is
affected by all domain points of the
random Oracle even if he only makes one
query the way this is usually fixed in
the quraan literature is to commit to
the entire hash function at the very
beginning of the reduction and never
change it or maybe he only changes very
selectively but this is going to open up
yet another problem which is we not only
do we need to extract this calm value
from the attacker but then we need to
program the random Oracle with whatever
response we got but the problem is we
don't know what tom is until we're
midway through the reduction at which
point if we've used the typical solution
we've already committed to the entire
description of the Oracle and we can't
change it so somehow we have to figure
out how to adaptively program h of
cannae star to be whatever challenge we
got from the verifier made execution and
the bulk of the Chauhan's techniques do
not let you do this so our main theorem
says actually you can get around this
you OPH Amir preserves knowledge
soundness and the contra mundum Oracle
and it also allows you to construct
signatures for identification protocols
so I'm just going to jump right into the
full idea so
place is going to build on some work of
mine also from last year so the the the
first step this part's not really the
interesting part but the first step is
that we're going to replace our random
Oracle model for our random Oracle which
define an equal probability for all
possible functions we're going to
replace this Oracle with a quantum eyes
diversion that put equal weight on all
possible Oracle's but now this Oracle
that itself actually a quantum state and
this doesn't cause any effect on the
adversaries outputs because basically
this Oracle is outside the adversaries
view for the entirety of the experiment
except via the query and what that means
is that the path for different Oracle's
can't interfere because the the Oracle
States is sort of outside of the
adversary State so doing this
transformation has no effect on the
output distribution of the adversary but
what it does is it allows us to actually
extract some useful information
so in this prior work I don't describe
the the result using this path
terminology what is the path terminology
is actually makes makes the statements
of the circuit main idea very concise
it's what I'm going to do is remember
I'm thinking of a path of the attacker
as the path for all these snapshots in
time which are their queries so if I
were to take the this quantum eyes
random Oracle and look at it in what's
called the primal domain so if I were
just to observe it what I would just see
is the hash function H and that doesn't
that that's not that interesting but
what I can do is something called the
quantum Fourier transform and I can
actually observe the Oracle on a
different domain called the Fourier
domain and
I were to do this what I would see is
actually some partial information about
the path the current path but the
adversary is in particular what I would
see is this function that I'll call the
parity of a path so the parity of the
path at a particular point X is going to
be what I'm going to do is I'm going to
look at all XY pairs along the path
and I'm going to X or the Y values
together so all XY z-- where the actions
whatever point I'm looking at so all for
all XY pairs where the X is the
particular input that I care about I'm
going to explore those Y's together and
I'm going to call this the parity of
that given path at the point X so if I
were to look I yeah question this
definition so X X is a point in the
domain of the random Oracle and
imagining the the point in the path are
pairs of input our input-output pairs of
the random Oracle and the way I process
the random Oracle to XOR the output into
the output good so what sort of it's
basically just a simple consequence of
what the for of the one of these Fourier
transform input-output rules but
basically what ends up happening if you
get in if you look at the this quantized
random Oracle in the Fourier domain you
actually magically see the partial path
information for every domain element of
the random Oracle you see the XOR of the
corresponding Y values from all XY pairs
on the top okay so this is going to be
our starting point and what we're going
what we prove is this informal lemma
which roughly says that if the parody of
a path at a particular point is
identically 0 then the path actually has
no knowledge of the Oracle at that point
this is so this isn't formally stated
more precise meaning but a roughly says
that if my if my passes so certainly
this is true at the very beginning at
the very beginning with the parody of a
package is all 0 and if at any point the
parody of my path is all there is zeros
at a particular point then
path has no knowledge of the Oracle
value H of X so a couple corollaries one
is that if I have a successful path for
the adversary that actually generates a
proof a valid proof they they the valid
proof includes the Oracle value of H of
the commitment and so that means the
parity path the parity of the path
evaluated at the commitment that they
ultimately output actually had to be
nonzero by the time they reached the end
of the of the interaction but how are we
gonna use this yeah for the trivial
reason that X does not occur in any of
the states that are that that you query
or you know there are sort of two points
where exit occurred but they even
interference it just might be a query on
a particular X Y and then a query on the
same X Y again yes I I could what this
shows is that I could have at some point
in time know what H of X was but if had
a later point in time I make the pair to
get my path at X 0
it actually means I don't know what H of
X is anymore yeah so another tool we're
going to need is something I'll call the
observation this is something we've
proved back in 2013 I expect some
versions of it were widely known in the
quantum crowd but it basically says that
I'll observing act can have an effect on
the output distribution of a later
observation why it says that it can't
mess it up too much in particular if I
knew that acts gave one of T possible
outcomes then observing acts can only
reduce the probability of any particular
output Y by a factor of Q so this is
actually just a really simple
consequence of
whether you want Akashi swords Jensen
inequality or just norm relationship
between one norm and two norm um it's
basically in one case you have this
common square as the other case you have
a square of a thumb and the relation
between those the the ratio between
those can't be more than the number of
elements in this film so if I observe X
and then later observe Y the probability
of observing Y come on down except by a
factor of P beauty's evidence right so
it's like on average over X yeah so I
observe X and then I forget what X was
okay yeah now note that this doesn't
work in the other direction if I were to
observe X and asked what the probability
of Y is and then I don't observe and
then say okay well what say I actually
didn't observe X I can actually get an
infinite increase in particular Y values
so this is only a 1 that's only a
one-way thing join that going from not
observant to observing can only reduce
by a factor of P so what we do roughly
is we generalize this to talk about
general tap so if it were possible so
imagine we have a partition of possible
paths maybe the partition is based on
which state the path goes through at a
particular snapshot in time or maybe
it's a more general partition by
partition all possible paths and imagine
that I can observe which element of the
partition I'm in if there if I do this
observation again it can only decrease
the probability of any ultimate outcome
by a factor of T where T is a number of
sets from my partition this is just a
sort of a straightforward generalization
of the observation level so what we do
is we describe a collection of
partitions or we describe a partition
for a collection of sets of paths that
will allow us to do query extraction so
we're we'll just focus on successful
path so path of the adversary actually
succeed it would also have the month
except the claim that we don't have to
worry
so among the successful pal how are we
going to partition well we know that a
successful path has to start out at
having as having the parity being a zero
because the Perry needs a zero
everywhere before you make a query and
at the end the parity of that path has
to be nonzero because you have to
actually know the hash value in order to
output it so what the partition will do
is will partition a path by the last
time the parody of the path at the
common value transition from zero to mod
0 so P I is a set of all paths whose
final time transitioning from 0 to mod 0
is that query I and we can actually
sample from these P eyes there's a
little caveat that we actually have to
we can sample what we can do the
measurement of the P is but only
assuming we know what the output of the
measurement is going to be and so in
order to actually make this work we have
to guess which I were going to get and
then if we gets wrong we just abort and
we lose and this means this having to
guess what I were actually going to get
causes us to lose an extra factor to the
number of queries in the reduction but
assuming we knew which I we were going
to get here's how we we measure I when
making the ice query we observe calm we
observe if the parity of the path calm
was zero
just prior to evaluating the query it's
not zero we know where actually the path
actually isn't in P I in we just abort
and otherwise we continue for every
later query we check that the parity of
the path remained nonzero and if it ever
goes back to the earlier words so this
has the effect of at the end of the
whole experiment we have selected if we
don't some boards we actually are we're
actually exactly where we want we have
exactly just the tab in the set P I
um paya just observing is still
conceptual in the classical setting or
is there actually a measurement involved
so there's actually is going to be a
measurement here right but the the point
is that um if we're on this set of paths
then comm actually is effectively
measure that query I already and so the
fact that we're observing it right our
observation of the comm just means we
sort of write it in some other space and
yeah if I wanted to be complete I would
need to do a couple more slides to make
sure that this works but you can
nonetheless show that exactly you get
exactly what you would hope for if you
were actually measuring the I value from
the path partition but yeah it's
actually but the the whole reason we did
all this is exactly so we can observe
the the con value with without hurting
or problem or probability of success by
too much right so now we have the column
value what we saw the second problem
what how do we embed the challenged into
the random Oracle so here we're going to
have a new idea which is what we said
that just before query I the parity of
the path comm zero and buyer limit list
means the adversary knows nothing about
H of comm so we should be able to do is
just replace H of comm with whatever we
want can be happy in particularly
current places with the verifiers
challenge the problem though is that now
we've reclassify wised the value of the
Oracle at the point column and so we
have no more access to the Fourier
domain with which we were evaluating the
parity of the current path and remember
we actually need to know what the parity
of the path is at the point comm in
order to do our partitioning correctly
because we're saying that our
have or all those who parody patcon is
non-0 after the ice Cleary
so we need something better and what
we're going to do is we're going to do
an alternate set of tabs where well okay
so here here is just we could have
imagined partitioning by saying we have
success by saying it's not by looking at
the eye where the first time we made the
transition from zero to Molitor rather
than the last time so this is another
partition of the path but this partition
doesn't work we can't actually
efficiently sample from this because in
order to carry out this partition we
actually need to know what comment at
the beginning in or so in order for us
to evaluate parity path calm at all
queries before the ice query but the
problem is that we haven't actually
observes what calm is until the ice
query for this partition doesn't really
work so the takeaway is we need a
partition that doesn't check parody of
the parody a calm once program because
once program we lose access to the
Fourier domain on at the same time we
need a partition that doesn't check the
period before before the ID query before
comma the worst focus leads to is a
different set of paths where we'll talk
about qi which are the successful path
that were 0 where the parity was 0 just
before the ice query and became nonzero
just after the I squared so this
satisfies both things that we want so i
being 0 before just before query i but
we don't care what it was and on all the
queries preceding i we don't need to
know what khan is and tell query i and
we also don't care about the parity
anymore after i because all we care
about is a transition from 0 or a by we
don't know what happens at all the other
points a lot week it's fine that we lose
access to the the parity the problem is
is that this these queue eyes are not
actually a partition and the over count
have that go back and forth many times
but the
zero one zero zero one zero um you'll
actually be counted twice in two
different cue eyes so we don't get a
partition and therefore there was no way
to apply this observation dilemma or
this generalization of it so what we do
is we actually come up with yet another
set of paths that turns out to exactly
correspond to the over counts of the cue
eyes and this other set of paths are
those where on query I we go for non
zero to zero and remember that we're
talking about successful paths here so
the overall path bill hustles in that go
from zero to non zero but these are eyes
will will be triggered everything when
you go from one zero back to zero in
somewhere in between and you can sort of
test for yourself and any occurrence and
our eye corresponds exactly to its over
count in the qi n we in fact give
another generalization observation lemma
that I won't go into the details here
but it basically says if this works if
I'm looking at by having something that
over counts than something that exactly
corresponds to the over count we get
exactly what we want and that's
basically the gist of our result I do
want to briefly mention how we relate to
this concurrent work by dawn chair
imagined and shots are so in our work we
actually I lied a little bit our set up
our eyes he's compensating that so they
added after the fact is actually much
larger cubic in a number of queries
instead of linear and therefore we
actually get a terrible reduction the
concurrent work didn't go through
anything with paths or anything like
that they actually give a very direct
algorithm and analysis so just sort of
magically work but it turns out that
their algorithm is essentially the same
of all we only realize this after the
fact
they're longer than with essentially the
same Abarth but what the are I I just
presents on a long flight because this
set of our I only has Q element
basically we only with Q squared one
because we have to guess what we have to
guess the measurement outcome at the
beginning and then another one because
hid from the observation mama okay so
that that's it for our acute long and I
just wanted to you know briefly say that
with with some of the recent advances in
the Kyurem literature from last couple
years
most major animals techniques have now
been ported to the quantum in the Moore
Oklahoma from way and so there's
actually a good reason for optimism
you know the quantum random Oracle model
very close with classical random Oracle
is a lot harder to actually prove
anything and the fact that we have all
these new techniques now perhaps
explains why the new counter example is
so contrived may actually know to
counter examples one from our original
work in 2011 is I'm uh turn the weird
timing model with artificial and then
another more recently um give a counter
example August I was getting secured in
the wall but not the queue own but it
doesn't correspond to any natural crypto
tasks and so sort of an interesting
question whether there actually is any
separation here yes what I mean by what
I mean with us I mean that the for
tonight what we give is an
identification protocol where the
verifier actually counts how long it
took the proofer to respond which is not
normal model turn identification
protocol where we imagine everything is
surveyed internet then you can break it
in the Kyurem
[Music]
models I'm not sure I mean the gist is
just um you in the quantum random Oracle
model you can use something like rover
search to get a polynomial beat up and
so if the so what this allows you to do
is to fall term taps a bit faster than
what could be done classically and then
you use the timing the verifier will
check that you solve the problem faster
than any classical algorithm could do
but a quantum algorithm can do it cheap
okay so in the last several minutes I
will go to the second part of
accomplishes are new techniques for
quantum rewinding and here suggest the
problem so how do we prove knowledge on
this of an interactive protocol well
usually what we do is we start with
something that you need to prove called
specials on them which says labs giving
a to transcripts any to transcript such
that the transcripts are different but
the first message is the thing that you
can actually extract a witness so this
is special comments and in the classical
setting special soundness implies not
ones countless and what's the classical
reduction well when we have an attacker
that comes in severe fire what we're
going to do is we're going to phone the
attacker one and then we're going to
rewind them using the hack that
classically we can basically always save
state and return to it at a later point
we're going to rewind the attacker to
just after they made their commitment
and then run them again is upon a fresh
challenge and the result is that we'll
get to transcript that both verify and
have the same first message and
therefore fundly to transcripts using
special finals you can extract a witness
so any proof that convinces the verifier
you can then extract the witness from
just based on the special found nets
which again is typically very easy to
prove
when we move the quantum though
extracting of the first response well
right so if I go back to here extracting
with first response in the quantum
setting there's going to irreversibly
alter the adversary State so we actually
can't return to their their immediate
post commitment state and all the things
that we don't get a guarantee that the
adversary works when we submit a new
challenge this problem was first
employed by Van de Graaff a couple
decades ago and this form a line that's
more recently with natural counter
example and we have a couple counter
examples one is relative to a quantum
well one of the wealth of a classic
Oracle these are at we actually
interestingly don't have any standard
model counter example but none of us
represents a proof technique barrier so
the good news is again we don't have any
standard model separation no no long but
the bad news is that we don't know how
to prove anything just run specials on
this and it's actually not enough to
prove anything you have these contrived
Oracle based counter examples so in
order to get the in order to prove now
know that we're going to need to add
some additional properties to approve
and there have been a number of works
doing this in the past but they all
basically involve they all require
modifying the existing constructions in
some way and the modifications will
generally revoke in reduced efficiency
right and in particular writing on the
examples applied to sale a bush FDC or
any of the efficient scheme based on it
so I'm gonna go
I guess rather quickly through the
remainder of my plied but the so the
basic idea is that we're going to use a
firework over that more or wats reduced
the problem of constructing
a proof of knowledge to something much
weaker what does the nurse say he says
that if we if we all know observe
whether the adversary succeeded in the
first round but don't actually observe
read the response from the first round
he actually shows that rewinding works
and if you combine that with something
that he called strict Hellmuth which
says that once you have the commitment
in challenge six that there's only a
unique valid response then you actually
get security
why because remember I have this
observation one more measurement memo
that says that if I observe something
and it only produces Cape possible
outputs then the probability can only
reduce by factor of K well in this case
k is going to be SB one because there's
only a unique response and so once I
already guaranteed to have a valid you
know quantum eyes transcript I can
actually over observe the response and I
won't I won't affect the success
probability until you actually get
knowledge on this and the problem is how
do you guarantee with strict on this
requirement oh yeah yeah last thought I
think is fine if you go over time so
it's a clock okay I mean I also have my
own my own time constraint I see right
so if we if we assume that rewinding
works if you don't observe the response
and you have this strict soundness
guarantee then you actually get
knowledge counters by applying the
observation level so Indra shows
actually this weaker guarantee hold we
don't observe this weaker guaranteed
hold in general so if you don't come for
the response but you just observe
whether the first one I've seen you
actually get the weaker guarantee I I
won't prove it my instance my intuition
my own personal intuition is that it's
another variant of this observation that
certainly very
I mean it predated our ulema but that's
sort of my intuition no measuring a
binary outcome does not change things
too much so to motivate our solution
what we're going to do a brief segue
into something called a collapsing hash
function so cocking hash function was
introduced by twin rule few years ago as
a generalization of collision resistance
and what a clapping hash function says
is that if you if you take a
superposition of inputs and you measure
the output so you apply the hash
function to the quantum state that's
your input and you just you observe what
what H of X is or you observe what X is
these will result in two different
quantum states border clamping national
champion guarantees is that they're
indistinguishable so what we do is we
basically take this notion and sort of
quarter to the Sigma protocol clipping
we define a notion of quantum procedure
protocols which says that if I observe
the output of verification and
additionally conditioned on it the
output of verification is Wong I either
observe the response or I don't but the
two cases are in computationally
indistinguishable they give you the
superposition responses and I either
measured the response or I did not but
in either case I whether the whole
transcript verified so this is an
aquatic park also that these two are
indistinguishable and we prove it's
essentially the same as sooner we show
that this is amol to to get knowledge
something so now we've reduced the
problem to trying to find a collapsing
signal protocol and for this talk
actually gonna focus on a simpler
problem the simple problem of finding
collapsing hash functions and turns out
that for say proving chef Sookie this is
a muscle what are the point to be used
to prove that this hash function is
collapsing this will be the last couple
minutes is where I will actually finally
talk about novices so what is this
attach function it's roughly you fix a
large matrix a and your domain element
or vectors whose entries are short and
you just compute the inner product mod Q
so this is the hash function its
closures this n Thunder sort in your
solution problem which can be reduced to
our lattice problem so we want to prove
that this is Claussen and now what what
are the existing collapsing hash
functions so a few works shown that
random Oracle's or various things
divided from and or gopher collapsing
and others also a work of own rule that
shows how to build clamps and hash
functions from lossy functions
unfortunately if this contains neither
random Oracle or along c function so
we're gonna have to do something
different and our solution is related to
the lossy function approach with
something called Associated lossy
function so five hash function H an
Associated lossy function is if it's
some function f that can be generated in
one of two ways
so what I'll do is we'll take an image
points for the hash function and I can
either generate a thermal velocity mode
based on an image point or in an
injective mode based on that image point
and the guarantee is that in the lossy
mode this function actually Maps all pre
images of Y to the same point whereas in
the injective mode the function has to
be injective on the
crema juice all right so I can generate
my functional so you give me any image
point I'll generate an auto description
of a function path in one of these two
modes that either maps all pre images to
one point or mob all pre images two
distinct points and the guarantee is
that when I hand you the description
function you can't tell what mode it was
used to generate it even if you know why
so what we show is an Associated loss a
function or not to imply collapsing and
the theorem proof is pretty
straightforward um for on the left here
I have the case where you observe the
output and a hash function on the right
have the case reads at the input so I'm
going to make some hybrids for the first
time grid and I will work the output of
the hash function I'll then generate a
lot female function app and if there is
the output of F applied to my input
because I generate that philosophy I
actually know that the entire state of
input actually all hast amount to the
same Z value when I apply it out and so
observing out prevent actually didn't
change anything this is just the the
measurement level again and then I use
the loftiness the security associate
along Z function to push to injective
mode
and then but when I'm an engine tip move
alerting the output of mass is actually
the same as observing information
theoretically is the same as observing X
because of the injectivity above so the
information theoretically will defy it
observe the output of a so I actually
must know what X is so it is actually
enough to give an associate Awasthi
function for a hash function and that
will prove collapsing or our theorem is
that actually fit as a fiddle RC
functions assuming lwe um and it's the
construction is exactly what you expect
so whenever a is if is this matrix the
finding a hash function to generate the
long C Mo's I actually ignore the Y
value all together and I just generate a
bunch of lwe the matrix of lwe samples
relative today and what is my monthly
function it takes this matrix inner
product with the input and does some
sufficiently course around it
and the point is that because the input
the SIS is short and the lwe sample has
a short error but the sort of air part
goes away and I'm left with a value that
depend solely on the output of this
meanwhile to generate the injective mode
i just generates uniformly random
samples and this is indistinguishable
security of the media by the security of
lwe and as long as I set my matrix to be
tall enough if I choose a uniformly
random matrix the function that map's X
to B times X and rounds will be
injective so the show's search has a
full set of RC functions and with our
theorem we now get that sis is
collapsing and what fighting will work
you can get that value by chefs keys
protocols collapsing and therefore a
completely thing there's one caveat that
the correctness of the lossy mode
actually needs a super polynomial Q
which we don't want to rely on
especially because the most efficient
protocols have only a polynomial to and
so we show how to fix SAT we need or the
last notion of la fille functions and
show that that's good enough yeah so you
know this probably you know gives you
pretty easily
somewhere statistically binding hash
function right and is that enough - is
that an alternate path to get to
collapsing um yeah I mean so
constructing um loss so constructing a
function is harder we want to show that
a particular hash function there quad
thing
so you would need to show right now I
mean I'm sure there's many ways to show
like let's just have the philosophy
functions but just because you can use
system build arm to build from
collapsing hash function isn't isn't
necessarily enough
but so you want to show that the sis has
function the a times X is collapsing
that's that is that right right and and
with a similar similar idea we can show
that on labor shuts Keys underlying
identification protocol awful collapsing
right those the reason we want to do
this - we don't want to modify you know
in the proof you wanna sort of maybe
make some mental experiment change the
distribution of a and so forth but
that's that you permit yes I mean that
yeah okay so here's it so I you know the
I guess the other question is you know
so now the security of the whole thing
is based on lwe as opposed to I get the
diene which only required sis right I
guess you could claim that if you break
lwe you pre exists in the quantum world
right but you know is that at the end of
the day you can base everything on sis
quantumly is that right yeah well again
or whatever law needed to go between LW
in assists so we you know we potentially
lose something in the reduction
yeah so the main takeaway is that
actually whereas before we only had
basically two families of wanting hash
functions my own personal takeaways that
clamping hash functions and also
probably collapsing similar protocols
are actually probably much more common
than previously thought because you
could imagine using totally crazy tools
to try to build The Associated loss a
function until your favorite hash
function use use indistinguishable the
obfuscation whatever you want and
actually maybe the show's want a finding
a counterexample the collapsing is
actually pretty hard and it's actually
then you know we don't have any standard
model examples of a collision resistant
hash function that is not collapsing and
maybe this is why that it's actually
very hard to try to show that no
possible fulfilling lossy function
exists even if you use crazy to lacayo
and the reason I'm interested in this
this last question is these counter
examples can actually use constructively
to build interesting quantum protocols
like want some money
so with that oh cool thank you for the
thing and I'll take any questions
alright let's quickly thank the speaker
and I do have questions excuse that we
don't have questions maybe we can take
questions offline maybe but you can stay
around for one or two minutes in case
you have questions and then I guess
let's just thank everyone again
[Applause]